les opérations de rapatriement des
touristes européens se poursuivre cette
semaine à partir de demain ce sont cinq
vols spéciaux affrétés par la compagnie
néerlandaise klm qui vont quitter le cap
et johannesburg des vols orchestrée par
les ministères des affaires étrangères
au total 250 français notamment vont
donc pouvoir rejoindre roissy charles de
gaulle au terme d'un voyage qui fera une
halte technique à la réunion fut
amsterdam aux pays bas encore faut-il
que nous soyons tous en bonne santé à
des tests devraient ainsi être réalisées
avant que nous ne montions dont l'avion
pour détecter les éventuels malades et
du coronavirus le rendez vous a été fixé
au petit matin dans un stade du cap
c'est de là que nous devrions être
conduits en bus escortés vers l'aéroport
et logistique rendue possible grâce au
suivi quotidien des ressortissants
français par l'ambassade et le consulat
de france pas un jour sans que l'une ou
l'autre des institutions notre en
contact avec nous répondant à nos
interrogations nos inquiétudes
un groupe wayne sapp a même été créés
ces dernières 24 heures pour répondre en
direct à noah dernières interrogations
concernant le vol de retour
un lien étroit qui a évidemment beaucoup
apaisée rassurer ces derniers jours pour
rappel elle c'est le 27 mars au premier
jour du confinement ici dans le pays que
tous les vols commerciaux internationaux
ont été suspendus notamment en
provenance des pays européens dits à
haut risque comme l'allemagne l'italie
ou encore la france il aura donc fallu
une dizaine de jours de négociations
entre les ambassades européennes et les
autorités sud africaines pour ouvrir ces
liaisons aériennes en direction de
l'union européenne